the Trump administration is blocking
shipments of semiconductors to Chinese
tech giant Huawei this is the Chinese
Communist Party threatens to sanction
several US lawmakers including Senator
Tom cotton who has appeared on this
program to call out China's handling of
the current virus pandemic among other
bad behavior Georgia congressman Doug
Collins just introduced his own
legislation on China he joins me now
konna it's good to see you this morning
thanks very much for joining us let's
get right to it your bill basically
sanctions and freezes assets of the
Chinese leadership tell us about it
exactly this time China decides if they
want to be a world economic power they
also have to be a responsible world
economic power they can't treat the
world like they treat their citizens
which is to keep them under oppression
and make them believe every bit of
communist doctrine that they want to
believe and what we're gonna do is say
if you want to actually be a part of the
world you need to be out there and give
a full accounting and international
accounting of what you did and what you
did not do it has become very apparent
that they were much more willing to
control it internally but yes ready to
cross the world China has a problem and
the problem is they can't be honest with
themselves and they can't be honest with
them with the international community so
we're gonna put it in the fact to give
the president a way to sanction we're
gonna Glen ought to his hands will give
him every tool until about to get them
to compete in a way that is fair in the
international market and if they don't
then fine they'll suffer the
consequences for it do you worry that
there will be consequences to that that
they're gonna push back I mean you
already have chinese state media
ominously threatening congressmen you
weren't on the list but Josh Holley was
on the list Tom cotton was on the list
they are watching each of your districts
to try to get back at you for coming up
with legislation against China and the
Communist Party well I hope become his
party's watching my name is Doug Collins
they can come after me whenever they
want to but I'm gonna stand with America
and I'm tired of watching Internet
intellectual property I'm tired of them
trying to steal pharmaceutical secrets
I'm tired of them letting their own
country be locked down while they send
people out of the country and then they
lie to it about the the to the world the
communist party must realize that they
may be able to try and keep their own
people down but that if that regime
isn't found in destined to fail we need
to make sure that if you're gonna have
any economic partner in the world they
have to be able to compete like
everybody else does and tell the truth
it seems like they can't do that even to
their own people so why would we expect
you from the red
in the world all right let me switch
gears congressman ask you about the
unmasking you heard the president's
response to what has taken place where
we see a number of high-level Obama
administration officials moving to tell
the world expose what was supposed to be
a private call between an incoming NSA
director and and the Ambassador to
Russia well it's it's amazing what we've
seen real we've been talking about this
for so long and now it just feels like
that what we've been talking about in
the corrupt cabal was struck in McCabe
and Comey and all of them in now Yates
and the rest but he now found something
different we now find it in the Oval
Office
not the oval office of president trunk
but the Oval Office of President Obama
who was asking about Flynn who had had
his own chief of staff unmasked him the
day that there was a meeting and oh by
the way Joe Biden were you asleep in
this meeting as well when you actually
were there and you told just this past
week that you knew nothing about
unmasking and you actually made a
request for unmasking this is the
problem that we're seeing right now is
that people are now waking up to the
real fact that there was an attempt to
take out a candidate and then a
president before he could get going and
the American people ought to be appalled
they ought to be demanded that why every
news outlet is not covering this the way
you have for the last few years and
maybe many of us have been screaming at
the top of our lungs that there was a
you know basically a coup attempt at the
highest levels and now we have it placed
right into the Oval Office and you still
don't see it on any of the news media
they actually used the media to leak
things classified documents in fact trey
Gowdy says that leaking classified
documents is a 10-year felony I know
we're waiting on John Durham but do you
see crimes being committed in plain
sight here how could it not be I agree
with Trey here this is just I mean it's
ridiculous how did that that information
had to get out from one of these that
had unmasked or someone that they gave
it to it's amazing to look at how the
mainstream media treats this president
they treat him as if he was different
they they'll believe anything if he was
accused of collusion or accused of doing
anything else with the Russians but yet
when it comes to the ones that they
think are the greatest in the world the
superheroes that they thought were
really nothing but a corrupt bunch of
you know thugs going around it looks
like now because they were tried to use
it they believe everything they say but
this goes by
you know way past this from the Clinton
email scandal into the discussion of
Russia and so what I want to see happen
here is this hold people accountable
somehow this information got out we now
know who on mask list start having the
investigation you know in Durham I
think's doing that but there needs to be
accountability because otherwise how can
they not happen to you and me and and
and throughout this whole hysteria let's
not forget they miss the real bad actor
and that's China while yourself and some
of your colleagues were investigating
China's moves like Devon Nunez over the
last several years we've reported that
congressman it's good to see this
morning thank you sir
we'll be watching your developments in
terms of that legislation Doug Collins